giá mùi sáng 18, tại Trung tâm Hấn Lệnh Quân sự Quốc gia bún các lượng quân đội,
công an cùng vũ khí, khi tại tham gia nhệm vũa tâm Hơi,
đến thành tổ hợp lệnh tập lần thứ 2, tới dự và chỉ lào,
ở đại tưởng phần bàn rằng quy vien bộ chính trị mộ trường mộ có phòng.
Tổ hợp luyện của mơm hai phần, thực hiện các lội dung gí lế,
nghe thức của đảng nhà nước và dưới bình dưới hoàn.
Nội dung dưới bình dưới hoàn có sự tham gia của hấn mùi sống nhìn
bà chăm cánh bộ chính sĩ của các đơn vị quân đội,
công an cùng hệ thống vũ khí, khi tại hiện đại.
Á lên tổ hợp lệnh lệnh này với các khối đi,
đậu tác cá nhân độ hình hàng ngang hàng giọt đã đều đẹp thống nhất.
Hối xe, họ quân sự đã thành thục đợi hình,
chuyển đợi hình hàng ngang hàng giọt,
giữa khoảng cách, cực li, tất lộ cơ động giữa các hàng xe,
và các khối xe theo đúng đợi hình dưới bên dưới hoàn.
Phát biểu chỉ đạo đậu vien khác lực lượng,
này tưởng phần bàn rằng chúc mừng,
điều dân những thành tích của các lực lượng tham gia tổng hạt luyện
chuẩn bị giữa bên dưới hoàn,
thực hiện vụ à tảm người,
mối hành động, mối việc làm của cánh bộ chính sĩ,
đều thể hiện phép tầm cao,
biểu lòng từ hảo dân tập.
Qua kiểm tra, các khối đi, khối đứng, khối khí tài,
xe pháo, khối quân nhạc,
đều mạnh mẽ hơn so với các tổng hạt luyện lần trước.
Đặc biệt, đây là lần đầu tiên các lực lượng hải quân,
càng sắp biệt, mộ đội vien phòng, tham gia giữa mình trên biệt.
Phát way tình thần các mặt tham tảm và cua khánh 2 tham chính,
tình cảm bộ chuyến sĩ không mừng lỗi lực,
mối tầm cao để thực hiện thành công dự vụ à tảm người,
mắt lại nghiêm từ hảo cho tổng quốc,
đất nước và cho chính mỗi đồng chỉ tham gia nghiệp vụ đặc biệt quan trọng này.